if you're a developer who wants some
Google Cloud swag stay tuned this video
is for you I don't know about you but
I'm way more likely to complete a task
if it's gamified there's something about
getting a badge or a prize for
completing a task that motivates me to
actually get things done that's why I've
been telling folks about my new favorite
way to upscale my Google Cloud knowledge
the arcade it's super simple complete
labs and you can earn digital badges the
badges you earn award you points that
you can redeem for Google Cloud prizes
like t-shirts mugs backpacks and more
and if you're not driven by Swag like me
you can also ch to make charitable
donations but here's the thing each game
is available for a limited time only so
start earning today all supplies last to
get started subscribe to the arcade to
activate your account and join Google
Cloud skills boost you can start playing
games learning skills and get points to
join our leaderboard and start redeeming
prizes check out the description of this
video to learn more and I'll see you on
the leaderboard